hey what's happening I'm Chuck nice hi
I'm Gary O'Reilly and this is the live
version of playing with science that's
right so we're here in studio and we
just finished recording a show or cosmic
chromatic cosmic queries but a playing
with science queries so about soccer yes
and everybody who is a fan of the show
or listens to the show knows that Gary
is a professional soccer player was or
what well once it's like being president
man once you did it you always okay I'm
done with that you're always a
professional soccer player once you got
paid once you got your first check from
that day forward it's like I'm a
professional soccer player all right um
the cool thing is that because of
Facebook life we could actually come to
you and take your questions anything you
wanted to know about the physics of
soccer because joining us via Skype is
Professor Eric Goths and he is the
author of a gold medal physics and a
professor at Lynchburg College in and
around sports gurus oh yeah you're going
to get some answers from a good
professor that I can assure you Randa
yeah Eric is Eric is a is just a wealth
of information on any sport that we talk
about it's always a pleasure to have he
loves you soccer so he's a good guy to
have on board him yeah so I say hi to
the people here hi everybody
hey hey Facebook so listen if you have
any questions about the physics of
soccer or the science of soccer or
anything like that or just you want to
know what it is to do certain things as
a professional soccer player you know
we've got it here for you so let's start
off with a question from a Jeff Miller
uh or Mueller one of the other Mueller
Mueller Euler you started again haven't
even so I said hey Chuck and Gary
because you talked about the different
playing surfaces and how impacts yeah
performance from a player's perspective
I know there are some players that
basically refused to play on turf and
FIFA certainly has a
out of regulations about this so what's
the deal okay so turf you as an American
term would refer to as an artificial
surface okay right so the old-school the
first generation turfs were some green
plastic laid down on concrete and when
that ball would hit the surface and it
would just bounce and keep going and
going and going and it was a horrible
thing to plan you had ankle knee back
problems because the surface was so
unforgiving now you have
fourth-generation surfaces and they are
far more true towards the natural
surface of grass so you would always
look to play on an on a very good grass
surface but I think the professor and
bring you in here the new structure of
playing surface is it's a feat of
engineering is it not now it is and it's
getting much more to simulate grass than
it's ever been before
it's unfortunate though that in 2015 the
Women's World Cup in Canada had to be
played entirely on a turf and the the
players hated it they were arguing that
you know the men would never have played
on a surface like that leg injuries
there's less give and it's hot I mean
they were breeding a hundred and twenty
degrees on some of those surfaces it's
very very hot yeah the thing is from a
planet point of view when the surface is
that hot you are going to get stress
through the footwear into the foot
blisters damage all sorts of things so
it's it's you play on it because in the
end it's the same for both teams but
you'd rather not you'd rather have that
game take place on a natural grass
surface that's for sure
cool hey let's move on to a by the way
Jeff Mueller said to me it's not like I
ever heard that joke before about my
name Mueller so sorry about that Jeff no
words here's um let's see Daniel
Cavanaugh says this how much money are
you guys taking from whatever I don't
even know what that means
no David Riojas who wants to know this
bending the ball
how as how is it done and here's here's
what I love about this what effect does
it have on the point of view of the
goalie
alright so professor you break down the
physics then I can break down the point
of view what it's like to be on the
receiving end of a free-kick from a
player's point of view so if we do have
a little video I mean the the ball is
going to be spinning and you get this
lovely banana kick filled with whipped
air and the air is going to be whipped
off the back as we talked about in the
previous show much like a boat rudder is
going to deflect water so when the ball
comes off spinning it's going to deflect
the air off in one direction and
Newton's third law says there's got to
push on the ball in the other direction
so you get this beautiful bending banana
kick and the the goalkeeper is of course
going to see the ball coming off the
boot and it's going to start curving so
the goalkeeper may try to pick up a
little bit of spin in anticipation of
which way to move so Chuck your favorite
phrase of our previous show drank crisis
Strad crisis absolutely yeah
so from from a goalkeeper crisis girl oh
yes right got that off his chest that's
good from the goalkeepers point of view
if you've got a free-kick taken and the
curve is so extreme the goalkeeper might
feel that that ball is going to travel
in a straight line but when it cuts back
late he might be fooled by it he might
then the the pace of the ball might
diminish towards the end rheumatica Lee
or it might continue so the goalkeeper
is all about placement from a free-kick
he'll hope the wall if he's put a wall
up does his job for him but if it
doesn't he's going to get beaten by pace
and by the spin rate on the ball which
then moves it into a place that he
cannot reach excellent
cool um okay here's Cody uh McIntyre
says why do more soccer players get
concussions than football players and
maybe you guys can talk about them
professor have you got a thought on that
well there are a lot of headers and
game so they're getting a lot of contact
they're not wearing helmets of course
you might get a ball coming in about 50
miles an hour and if your head is not
prepared for it if you're getting hit
with the ball and you're not bracing
yourself or it's not hitting your head
and the ideal spot kind of at the top of
the the forehead up here if it's hitting
maybe on the side if you're if your head
can move a cup an inch or two this
collision is going to take place in you
know hundredths of a second so you might
have something close to 50 G's of
acceleration on your head and anything
close to there or even greater is going
to cause a concussion now the other
thing is when you jump to header board
you invariably aren't jumping alone
someone is going to compete with you and
that allows for a potential for clashing
of heads from my own experience I can
viciously attack an opponent elbow with
my nose oh and that that happens and
yeah things go wrong from there so there
that's why possibly I'm from the point
of view of numerics I don't know whether
one is greater than the other from
football to soccer but there are points
where you will find collisions happening
and possible concussions coming out of
it Wow all right I lost this person's
question but I believe his name is chin
Jang hyung and he wants to know
Bernoulli's principle can you explain
that professor and how does it apply to
soccer
so Bernoulli's principle is sometimes
used erroneously to explain the Magnus
effect the idea is that you need a
laminar flow a lossless energy flow of
air going around an object where you get
a high pressure on one side and low
pressure on another if I just take two
pieces of paper together like this and I
blow between them they come together and
the idea is that I'm creating lower
pressure in the middle where there's a
high speed of air and a small pressure
on the outside where there's low speed
and that the pressure difference leads
to a force on the paper the Magnus force
is more about the way in which the
boundary layer of air is shed off of the
ball it does have a similar explanation
to the Bernoulli effect though Professor
how cool was that demonstration with two
pieces of paper that was everything I
mean had fabulous so okay so you've got
this pressure divided and that's again
the sort of thing but we're just
basically any projectile we see in sport
from a baseball to a soccer ball well
you know it in your car if you get too
close to a big tractor-trailer you feel
a little bit of a pull toward the
tractor-trailer because there's a air
rushing between the two of you that's
creating a low-pressure zone in
tornadoes and hurricanes you see roofs
get blown upward because the pressure in
the house where the speed of the air is
essentially zero you have a large
pressure inside and a small pressure
outside there you go all right one last
question then we got to wrap things up
Robert Williams wants to know this how
much impact does the shoe a player wears
have on all of the things that we're
talking about so how important is the
soccer shoe or what you guys guys called
the boot yes we do yes it's very
important and the the accuracy in which
the players are kicking I think area
talked about kicking on the where the
laces are I mean you're going to get a
lot more accuracy if you can put a
little bit more of the boot on it than
just a straight toe kick it'd be
analogous to using a putter and golf I
mean you're always going to kick on that
wide-open face you're never going to
turn at 90 degrees and kick on the point
you know on the on the golf ball when
you're putting so the stud length is
also important depending on the type of
surface you're playing the next game
you're playing how quickly you want to
run stop you know players are going to
be selecting their their stud lengths
and that's that's an important part of
engineering science right now it's an
important part of everything that
professor stud length is my life okay
did we did we do we stream off course
they listen I set that on the tee for
yes you did yeah and yeah just hold like
I'm telling you like a big giant great
fruit yeah one down the plate and that
was an empty net by the way professor
tester that hammered that strated I can
help welcome oh yeah doing that a
problem
hey listen you know why we do this
because we want you to know that we have
new episodes every Wednesday night of
playing with science happening on tuned
in and so make sure you check us out for
all the episodes on to 10.com slash
playing with science yes - nen comm PLAs
splash playing with science in its every
sport that we get into not just soccer
and if you love science and you love
sports then this is the place for you
and let us know if you want to subject
addressed we're at Chester hey anything
you want to talk about we are game to do
it because we learned just as long just
we learn right assault we learn right
along you as you learn okay what he said
different hey guys until next time I'm
Chuck nice I am Gary O'Reilly this is
playing with science